this week our series america's child
care crisis is looking at the growing
problems with child care and possible
solutions this is a very serious problem
during the pandemic the federal
government authorized more than 50
billion dollars in emergency funding for
states to assist struggling child care
facilities about half of child care
providers surveyed over the summer said
they would have closed without that
money but that help is only temporary so
there's a problem jan crawford looks
into what states did with the funds and
what more can be done now
on the west side of chicago even the
well-established carroll robertson
center for learning is struggling we
have a robust wait list it's about 100
families but we can't yet open this
classroom because we have to hire three
qualified teachers ceo bella mote says
at the height of the pandemic she feared
the worst we were on the brink of
collapse for many they did collapse
right early childhood organizations so
but you were on the brink we were
worried we were worried you bounce it to
me but novel solutions at the state
level helped her center and others avert
disaster for now
tapping into federal emergency pandemic
money illinois has allocated more than
one billion dollars in child care grants
which has meant relief for child care
worker and parent ivana brown i felt
helpless when i thought that i wouldn't
be able to work because i couldn't find
child care and i know
a lot of people didn't have the option
that i had like i was grateful that i i
work at a child care center it's one
approach meant to solve a critical
problem made worse by the coronavirus
helping parents find affordable child
care while helping the centers attract
and keep quality workers you've got to
pay the workers properly in order to
keep this industry going and it already
was in crisis now or so it's hobbling
the economic recovery that most of the
people many of the people that are
looking for work can't find child care
illinois governor jb pritzker has issued
child care workers one thousand dollar
bonuses and offered three months of free
care to parents looking for work if
we're not investing in our young
children we're creating a terrible
future for ourselves so it's an
investment in the future not just in
helping people get back to work so they
can pay their bills we have to stop
thinking about
things in one year increments
investing in young children means that
you're going to get a 20 30 40 year
return
illinois along with states like kansas
and tennessee are using relief funding
to reduce the amount low-income families
have to pay out-of-pocket michigan new
mexico and others are upping the amount
they reimburse providers for children
that receive government assistance more
plans are being announced each week with
the aid that's coming in we've gone in
and we're able to change certain things
update the hvac
change the flooring we're able to do
certain things to make sure that it's a
safer place for the kids new york has
given grants to providers like jasmine
corneal who is hoping to reopen one of
her three new york city child care
centers forced to close last year that
literally was like our lifeline the
programs are here they're here to
stabilize our industry
but the stabilization is supposed to be
for about six months and um this
pandemic is still going
and families still need
so
where do we go where do we go from here
in his buildback better plan president
biden proposes a massive spending
increase that would expand child care
access and cap costs my plan gets us
back on track
provides two years of high quality
preschool for every child in america the
biden plan remains stuck but growing
bipartisan recognition that help is
needed has priskar and others optimistic
what do you see as the future here for
states
once that federal money goes away we
need the federal government to step up
annually it can't just be a one-time
thing the federal government should be
investing in early childhood just like
states are mote hopes some of these
pandemic era policies endure and that
this focus on early childhood is a spark
for change
never have i seen an opportunity where
some of the core issues that have been
ignored or not understood they've
surfaced now there are creative
solutions that we have in this moment of
time so out of this crisis you really
believe this is now an opportunity i do
i think it's ours to throw away for cbs
morning's jan crawford chicago
gail we talked about this yesterday this
is important yeah our kids are the
future and government needs to step in
not just annually but every year child
care breaks the budget of a lot of
middle class families it is very
expensive one of the ideas in the in the
biden build back better plan is an idea
that would cap child care costs uh at
seven percent of income so if you're
making 70 grand a year in your household
you pay no more than five in child care
costs that's game changing for a lot of
families so many other countries guys
have seemed to figure this out and we
are still struggling with this
on a daily in our birth rate our birth
rate's going like this yeah and if i'm
getting older and thinking social
security better be around when i retire
we need more people to grow up pay taxes
and be part of our world nothing's more
important than your children